[Music]
just go to elijah in austin hey what's
up elijah how are we doing
i i don't even know how to really phrase
this question i guess i'll
i'll lead with the most shocking
part of it i feel
um portrayed
betrayed by god
and i'm very angry at him right now and
i need to figure out how to get past
this
man number one just i don't even i don't
even know where we're headed here but um
thank you for being brave out of the
gate man
um
wha what are you betrayed and angry
about my man
okay um retired army
um i've been to iraq afghanistan kosovo
germany
tons of places
um
so i've been the hill and i've i've
accepted it
and in my prayers
um the only thing i ever asked god for
was to uh not put my
put me in my marriage
what my mom went through which um my dad
died of
colon cancer when i was nine
and i watched it breaker
and um
i found the love of my life in germany
we got married in 2013
a week after we got married we found out
she was pregnant
two weeks after we got married we found
out that she had stage three
inflammatory breast cancer oh no
so we went through the whole pregnancy
with cancer
um we got through it
um
she never expected to live very long
um
her
mission in life was to give birth to our
youngest son and she told me um
you know when i pass away it's it's your
job to take care of them i'm just gonna
get them here
so that was kind of the plan and then
um
we were blessed and
and um
things continued on for eight years with
her being you know
little flashes of cancer but mostly in
remission
and um this past
march she went to the hospital
um she had a small tumor she was
supposed to get some routine surgeries
and they were gonna you know they had a
whole treatment plan and everything
and um she never made it out of the
hospital i ended up having to take her
off the ventilator on april 7th
four days after my birthday
um she was only 32 years old
and it's literally the only thing i've
ever asked god not to do to me and and
it's happened and now i'm here
you know almost three months later
with four kids in the house
um
we started building our dream house um
back in november i closed on that on
thursday so what are two days
and it all feels wrong because yeah this
whole dream was was for her and she's
not here to enjoy it
yeah and
and i'm just trying to figure out how to
navigate through that
if you were sitting with me right now
um
i'd give you a hug
and i would hold the hug past the time
when it was
awkward
to when you could feel
my body telling your body that i love
you and i'm sorry
what's happened to you should happen to
nobody
i'm sorry man
thank you
how old are your little ones
17
14
13 next week and eight
so the first three are from a previous
relationship but
um she was definitely the mom of all
these kids
sure
well that means three of them have
experienced loss twice now huh
yes okay
so
man i'll give you all time you need what
where do you want to start when you
start with nuts and bolts what comes
next we can start with god we can start
with
you
we can start with parenting where do you
want to start man you tell me
wherever you want to take me
i'm willing to go
well you tell me we lost yeah you too
um let's start with god
um
so
the best i can
in my study for those listening i'm a
person of faith okay
um
probably not a traditional person of
faith um i tend to make everybody
uncomfortable wherever i go
um but the best i can dig into it is you
got about four options okay elijah
okay that god's not real
none of this is real
that god's absent he's a clock maker he
spun the thing up and then walked away
from it just it's gonna be what it's
gonna be
the third option is god caused this for
some grand reason um
and he could only do his grand reason
with a trail of devastation and
heartbreak and loss
or the fourth
is that god can't or god doesn't
cause this type of god doesn't cause
cancer he doesn't let cancer happen
and that in fact when cancer happens and
cancer takes everything that god's with
you in the smoke and the ash
and unfortunately
there's
church systems
built around all these different
pictures
fortunately you get to pick
and what i would tell you as someone
who's seen it all
you've been all over the world as you
said you've been to hell
um i had a very clear understanding
because i read a lot
and then i started sitting with people
who had died
i started cleaning brains off of walls i
started helping move bodies
and then my picture shifted dramatically
okay
and so
at this point in my life and again feel
free to leave mean comments internet
people
i don't believe in the phrase
things just happen for a reason i do
believe that reasons and meaning can be
made from pain
i do believe that
so all that to tell you is
if you believe in
god he can handle your anger he can
handle your rage
feel free to feel betrayed feel free to
be heartbroken
all of those feelings are right and good
and i would even say they're holy
okay
not for a second
remember if you're a christian that
jesus got down on his face in the garden
the night before and said can we do this
another way
right
yeah so feel free to be upset and
heartbroken and mad
the next step is
people around you are gonna say the
dumbest stupidest things
because we have no capacity for being
uncomfortable
and so when somebody else gets cancer
when somebody else gets sick when
somebody else loses a loved one we get
uncomfortable we don't know what to do
with that and so
um
we wrap those things up in stupid little
sayings that we'd knit on pillows or put
in greeting cards
like god needed another angel or
it was just her time or you'll find love
against people say stupid things like
that that are painful and hurtful and
what i would tell you is
um
let that go like a vapor
okay okay don't hang on to that that's
people trying to love you and love
themselves in the only uneducated
unskilled way that they know how and
it's exhausting and frustrating just let
that
go like like cotton candy okay
um
however you reconcile god's
participation in this is
i mean you can find scripture to back up
whatever you want to think about it
quite honestly
and so it really comes down to
what helps you get to the next day into
the next day into the next day where do
you find peace
and i'll tell you peace is gonna be a
long time coming for you
okay do you remember back in basic
way back then do you remember basic
training
yes how long was yours six weeks
um nine weeks plus another six weeks and
i was lucky enough to join like two
months before 9 11. so it was it was bad
okay
so you remember on week one of that six
weeks
you knew there was an end date to this
thing
yes and when we have an end date we can
do anything
but you also remember when the drill
instructor would say you're going to run
till i get tired watching you
yes it was hell right because you didn't
know how long we were
running what you need to understand is
you've entered a space
that there's not a termination there's
not an end date on when the hurt stops
and so as a person who seeks control in
situations which is what you're going to
want to do
i'm going to tell you to start opening
your hands up
and probably i'm just guessing that
because you're a military guy i may
correct me if i'm wrong your tendency is
to walk into a situation especially one
of chaos and find control asap
yeah
and that's the opposite thing that you
need to do here you need to fight that
impulse with everything you got
okay
you're going to have to you're going to
feel underwater you're going to feel
like you're going through the motions
you're not going to be able to breathe
something you're not going to be able to
taste and then occasionally you're going
to smile and you're going to laugh
or you're going to see a really
beautiful woman at work and then you're
going to be overcome with shame and
guilt and frustration and anger and
that's just going to start to loop am i
on to something
yes okay
myself you're allowed to laugh
and you're allowed to wake up for that
one moment when you forget that she's
gone and think that was a hell of a
night of sleep
and you're allowed to see somebody who's
beautiful and think man she's beautiful
that's not a betrayal of your wife okay
okay
this is your body learning how to do
basic things again and it's gonna have
to relearn
all right so i just i threw a lot at you
there i'm gonna stop tell me what you're
thinking what you're feeling
um well i'm writing everything down
because because you're cause you're a
military guy
yeah
good call
yeah and um yeah this is stuff i wanted
to look at and study and
everything is just kind of true
everything i mean it's been almost three
months
so
i've gone through all of this and i've
kind of
just taking it day by day
and um
i'm looking at the new house as an
opportunity to get away from all of the
people saying stupid things
where no one really knows me so um
yeah this is this is all here's here's a
frustrating thing about other people
kind of like if you were dropped if you
got dropped in the ocean
and you were there for
six days
and you were rescued
what's the first thing you would need
is
water
the thing that almost killed you
is the first thing you need it's a
different kind of water in fresh water
but you need water
and so isolating yourself from people
is going to be helpful
sort of but the only way through grief
like this of this magnitude
because this is shape shifter right the
only way through grief of this magnitude
is with other people
and so i get the impulse to hide i've
got some i've never experienced grief
like you're going through i cannot put
my head in your seat right now looking
at my two little kids and the thought of
my wife not being here i can get choked
up real fast thinking about it
because i don't i have gone all in to
the point that i don't
understand how i would take a next step
what i know is you just do
and when i can't take another step
that's when my friends and community are
there
okay
so i'm gonna rattle some things off for
you right now
um and you don't have to write these
down um in fact i will uh i'll type
these up and i'll send them to you how
about that i'll email it to you perfect
and um that way you can just listen
if you don't already you've got to get
some men in your life asap okay
okay right away
the second part of that immediately is
you've got to get very clear and brave
about speaking your needs out loud
i need someone to help do my yard
because i can't get out of bed today
i need someone to help with my wife's
closet
because every time i go in there and see
her clothes i can't breathe
okay okay that's probably not your style
it's probably not your jams to tell
people you need help with stuff you're
the guy that people call when they need
help
yes
it's time for you to
uh do the brave hard thing and that's
ask for help i need a group of people to
commit to making me food for the next 30
days because i can't when i get home
from whatever i'm doing during the day
and i see my eight-year-old i can't move
because my eight-year-old looks just
like my wife
okay
and you should be very specific about
those the third thing is and i'm just
throwing this out there okay people are
gonna be mean to be on the internets i
don't care um
as hard as it i don't go run out and get
remarried okay
no that's definitely not the plan okay a
lot of the the data on people who run
out and within 90 to 120 days are
remarried is astounding
and i get it there's this idea that i'm
just gonna fix this pain right now i
hurt so bad um i'm so lonely i'm so i
feel like my part of my lungs are gone
because they are right
you're gonna have to do things on your
own
that means you're gonna have to get a
group of guys that you go fishing with
once a week that you get together and do
chips and queso with that you go grab a
drink with that you go hang out with
the tendency is to lock down and make
your life about those four kids
and that any minute you're not with them
is somehow abandoning them too on top of
your wife's passing and that's not
accurate
you've got to stay whole and well
they can't feel like they it's their
responsibility to make sure dad's okay
it's not their job okay
and kids are super perceptive and
they're super loving and they will take
that role on and it's really tempting to
drop our shoulders and let them run the
house
that's too much weight for a 17 or a 15
year old or a 14 year old or an eight
year old to carry
they need their daddy
which means dad needs to go exercise dad
needs to eat right dad needs to have
guys he goes and does stuff with whether
that's going to the gym shooting hoops
whether that's getting together once a
week and grandma comes over whatever
that looks like okay
okay um how are you financially you said
you're buying a house this sounds like a
big old mess
um i'm great financially i'm retired um
my income is over
six figures being retired so i'm good
excellent okay was there a life
insurance policy on your wife
yeah for um
six figures as well so obviously just
kind of sit in a money market
okay
um do you feel comfortable moving into
this new house
yes okay
um
the rule of thumb that my the guy who
trained me was actually a counselor and
he's then he became my supervisor um
the guy who trained me um
said no major decisions for six months
to a year
so if you can breathe inside that home
that was quote unquote y'all's home
move in and just sit for a bit
okay
let the smoke clear and let the ash
clear of the explosion that just
happened and then you can assess the
situation it's taking a step back right
that's it's back to your military
training
yeah we're gonna we're gonna step back
and re-um
like take it take a new inventory of the
landscape there that one's hard
um and then over that course of six
months to a year man that's when you
start to reimagine your life
i had this plan and now i got a new one
am i gonna live here am i gonna move am
i going to get a new job am i going to
go to med school like what am i going to
do
and culminating in that end of that is
that one scary terrifying question which
is
what are we going to do now
right
this is not the time for
bravery i can do it all myself
this is time for sitting down and
dropping your rucksack on the ground and
weeping
and saying why me
okay okay
this is saying those magic words to your
kids i don't know
okay
okay
where are we at now
um
there's a little bit of clarification
what should i look out for
um
with the kids with
their mom their mother figure being gone
is there something
um specifically that i should do
um i mean i've gotten us into church
since the since she passed
um
and i got her buried two miles from the
new house which is why i'm going there
so we can grieve that did they go to the
future did y'all have a funeral
yeah the kids go
yes okay
um
an important thing is to say your name
an important thing is to
acknowledge her
an important thing is when those kids
come in and one of them just randomly
starts crying and can't they're just
they'll be cutting a sandwich in the in
the kitchen
and will drop the knife and you'll think
they chop their finger off and they
follow the floor weeping
that you don't go say get up quit
whining that you go sit on the floor
with them and hold them
okay okay
think of this as a raging river
that just broke the dam
trying to rebuild the dam while that
thing is running is of no use the best
thing to do is to let that water run
right okay that system's got to equalize
itself
and for your eight-year-old it may for
all the kids it's gonna take it may
equalize over a lifetime
okay
um i'm gonna save the watch out for this
is in this let's get six months down the
road and i want to talk with you i want
you you and i to to to catch back up
okay
um
instead of looking for what's wrong i
want you to double down on connection
even if you said something like i want a
daily hug with all of you 20 seconds a
day 30 seconds a day
and if you're not a hugger it's time to
get weird man
okay
okay
and say i want morning hugs and
nighttime hugs and if your older ones
are like dad am i hugging you your kids
like i don't hug you they don't have to
don't force them but
say um
i need hugs i want hugs
i want to give hugs
and like i said there's that moment when
you hug somebody and then they hug you
back and then they relax and then they
get tense again and if you can hold a
hug through that
then their whole body goes limp
and that's what we're looking for true
connection
okay yes
so um i threw a ton at you
i'll uh
we'll type up some notes and send them
to you and then we'll clip this call and
get it sent to you right away okay
okay it'll be rough and uncut but we'll
get it to you right away um i'm also
gonna send you a copy of my new book
in no way shape form or fashion is it
gonna solve your i mean you're just in
the throes of deep deep grief and you
need to be there for a while okay
okay
um but it will give you some tools on
how to navigate it's basically like a
raft
um and some and some
some rowing instructions for when you're
in that river it can get you out of the
river but it can tell you how to
navigate a little bit
okay great thank you i appreciate it um
and
know that i'll walk alongside you every
step of the way okay call me anytime
email me anytime reach out on instagram
anytime and i will um i'll make myself
available as i can to you man
[Music]
thank you for giving everything you gave
everything
and your wife sounds like she was a
powerful strong extraordinary woman and
i'm sorry this happened
and um
for people who are listening if you
disagree with my theology that's fine
you can come meet at my house you're
still welcome over
and
elijah if you end up being you know i
disagree with you great man
i'm interested in you finding peace
it's been my experience that god shows
up in the ashes
[Music]
so i feel a little bit less alone or a
lot less alone
and often when the smoke clears
i've stopped asking the question where's
god and i start asking the question
where's god's people
and so i hope you your church will rally
around you too
i love you man and thank you for being
brave and thanks for calling